après ce n'est pas un racisme c'est quoi
le racisme c'est une ce sont des
discriminations des personnes victimes
des discriminations en raison de leurs
origines supposées ou réelles ou de leur
couleur de peau alors est ce
qu'aujourd'hui une personne blanche et
refusés à l'entrée d'une boîte de nuit
pour sa couleur ou pour un logement pour
sa couleur ou d'un emploi par rapport à
sa couleur non mais quand vous entendez
les cas qui sont soulevées par m goldman
est quand même là qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
vient là et c'est insulter bon et ça qui
est passé à tabac et une minorité mais
il n'a pas été repoussé d'une mois deux
nuls et une minorité c'est une minorité
mois pour moi c'est une minorité ce
n'est pas la majorité et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui quand vous avez
maintenant que c'est pas que c'est pas
la majorité parce que je pense qu'ils
ont peur aujourd'hui qu'ils sont blancs
bien mais non aujourd'hui on n'a pas vu
les barrières étaient de mon
connaissions les amènera des condamnés
il existe des actes anti blanc il
existait aussi des personnes qui ont été
condamnées pour du racisme anti blanc on
a 47 % des français qui considèrent que
ce processus existants pour la clarté du
débat jean cette alice cordier vous êtes
militante et présidente du collectif
nemesis un collectif féministe
identitaire ça veut dire quoi c'est le
féminisme droite au nom du nom s'est
faite aux femmes puisque les françaises
connaissent le nom leur quotidien c'est
tout on est on est confronté aujourd'hui
à des problématiques et d'ailleurs vous
parlez de droite mais céline pina je
crois que c'est une écrivaine de gauche
et qui elle parle du fait notamment que
certaines femmes qui ne portent pas le
voile dans certains dans certaines
contrées de france je dirais sont
discriminés et elle n'ose plus sortir
sans le voile est ce que ça ce ne serait
pas une frappe de vous reposer une
question non j'ai juste finir si c'est
une question j'ai juste finir s'il vous
plaît au sol vous passez plus souvent à
la télé que moi donc voilà est non mais
pour finir de mai des raisons
c'est une chose sur laquelle on peut
être d'accord c'est ça ou pas c'est
moins souvent chez pour l'instant aller
c'est incomplet et par rapport à ça on
ressent moins en tant que femme blanc je
ressens une crainte dans l'espace public
dans certaines zones évidemment parce
que oui il existe un racisme anti blanc
voilà et non mais les choses n'ont pas
de racine a devancé pas du raid lancé en
effet des violences nommer les choses
non il faut nommer les choses comme elle
a été violentée n'est pas d'accord que
c'est créer de la discrimination en
fonction d'une rafale du score du jeune
femme d'origine est d'avoir peur dans la
rue c'est pas une discrimination le fait
que je puisse pas m'en tombent il ya les
anciens sera une version n'a pas que la
liste c'est la ville discrimination
madame vous savez moi j'ai peur pour ma
vie certains n'ont pas d'emploi d'accord
ok c'est du racisme et je le reconnais
entièrement il ya du racisme en france
envers les noirs envers les arabes
envers les chinois envers les
communautés asiatiques y en a pour tout
le monde est là aussi pour les français
est aujourd'hui les français ils ont
perdu 80 des français peuvent être aussi
ne pas nous ont pas forcément mais voilà
la question que voulez vous la question
que vous allez vous poser c'est le
collège m goal d'arrêt m goal danel par
année que les réunions n'ont mis que
c'était quelque chose qu'il révulsait
est ce qu il ya de la mixité raciale
dans votre collectif oui totalement
pourrait vite à le visiter vient vous
donnerez vous viendra là j'aimerais bien
franchement j'aimerais bien
faire un tout petit peu mais bon
j'aimerais c'est une seconde alice
cordier ça s'apprend quelle forme ces
discriminations faut être précis
aujourd'hui ce soir je sais qu'on sorte
de la théorie pour des cas pratiques et
illustrations pratiquement ce soit
quelqu'un qui regarde le sava par
aurélien tâche visiblement ne doit pas
habiter à peu près dans les mêmes
endroits pour un show du collège unique
est une question de revenus chez karl de
la même région et du coup pour expliquer
un tout petit peu ça va être de
l'insultent ça va être de la menace ça
va être de la violence psychologique
parce qu'elle existe aussi cette
pression le fait voilà de sentir
discriminés consorts sans voile ça peut
être ça aussi c'est une forme de
violence et une violence qui existe et
je pense qu'on devrait un tout petit peu
plus la regarder aussi donc ça va être
voilà sept quelque chose de violent
reste et voilà mais ça peut être aussi
assez douces avec moi dans ma classe on
m'appelait la blanche parce que j'étais
la seule blanche de ma classe mais je
suis désolé moi j'ai pas j'ai pas aimé
qu'on me limite à ma couleur de peau je
pense que je suis autre chose non ce
n'est pas une agression inadmissible a
bloqué une agression inadmissible mais
moi je réalise la noire non mais c'est
la situation inverse sur s2 blanc avec
une noire j'aurais appelé la noire à mon
avis je pense que tous d'accord